the abuse scandal has spread to the very
top a Brazilian football Santos FC one
of brazil's most famous clubs home of
Pele its most famous player of all time
and now home to the most explosive
allegation yet I don't think any club in
the whole world is immune to potential
abuse it's little surprise Andi would
woods trip helping authorities stamp out
abuse has brought him here the director
of Santos Soccer Academy recently
suspended accused by a 19-year old
former youth player of sexual assault
when he was just 11 is the tip of the
iceberg
definitely bungee you know this this
individual that's come forward and you
know we don't know if it has or hasn't
happened but if that's proven then he's
an extremely brave person and could
change this country in the future
attitudes are changing here slowly for
this next generation of Santos youth
players there is growing awareness of
abuse in the game but the challenge is
getting players to speak out Santos FC
won't comment while the police
investigation is under way but the
scandal is prompting a national
conversation that Brazil hasn't had
before a former Palmyra's player who
suffered abuse nearly 40 years ago
breaking his silence early now I own
poor boy looking to get his career oh
that court who is famous because he's a
big team he did something with me my
word with his words nobody would go
there on my side so I would have the the
whole team against me I don't have never
mentioned that way anybody I'm 56 now
it's happening when there was 18 years
later and little has changed
poverty is high and football is powerful
more than 11 million people live in
Brazil's slums crime is high life
expectancy low if a football agent comes
calling with a ticket out of here a
child of family
we'll take it not knowing what it could
cost we're playing with dirt here kids
growing up in these favelas really do
have next to nothing we're talking the
most basic of things food shoes talent
scouts often come and recruit from these
really poor areas and if your child gets
an opportunity to join a club it's a
golden ticket it means they leave all
this behind life can be transformed from
this to this
Santos like most clubs in Brazil has a
hostel for its youth players but for
vulnerable boys far away from home
there's little protection from abuse the
power of football and extreme poverty
has harbored decades of abuse in Brazil
a dangerous cocktail that still exists
in the sport today sunny Lockwood Sky
News Santos